[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another installment of what
you never knew this is where we take a
look at all the little touches not
behind the scenes but right in front of
us and today we're gonna take a look at
the gremlins movies the first one may be
a classic send up to traditional monster
films and the second one that straight
of satire of its own product but what
have you missed about them with so many
creatures of so much variety in so many
scenes it's easy to overlook some of the
hidden gems that were always in plain
sight to see that clever they're subtle
and they're all over the place let's not
waste any time let's jump right into it
with the gremlins movies most of the
people know the bigger names in these
movies but the slipping cameos are far
too many to count
no let's try anyway there's Steven
Spielberg the movie's producer the
movie's composer Jerry Goldsmith makes
an appearance in both the first and
second film though you didn't know it
yet you would later see these twins in
Terminator 2
Billy's boss would eventually go on to
be korben Dallas mother a brochure for
the clamp cable artery channel there's
Dick Butkus at the salad bar John Astin
of Adam's family Fame as the janitor and
we clearly see Billy showing his cartoon
to one of the greatest Looney Tunes
animators of all time Chuck Jones and
back there even playing one of its
cartoons in the background this is
bidding seeing how the film's director
Joe Dante will go on later to director
Looney Tunes he'll thankfully not this
one as such it makes sense that the
director would give himself a cameo
doing exactly that directing let's just
hope he's nothing about playing Brendan
Fraser and anything else
we all remember kids out of nowhere
monologue about Santa and why she hates
Christmas he slipped and broke his neck
died instantly that's how I found out
there was no Santa Claus but while that
one was played up for drama the we think
the sequel plays it for laugh something
terrible happened to me my dear on
Lincoln's birthday I was six or seven
this man see beard and a hat with just
like Abe Lincoln apparently in this one
it has so little to do with anything
that they don't even let her finish and
apparently it was so funny that the
actor playing Billy actually starts to
crack before leaving the frame now let's
be honest who can blame him
I remember I keep one of these here
that's intestine what the hell kind of
high school teacher is this he performs
all these experiments himself he doesn't
keep food away which he knows he's
supposed to do he doesn't turn on the
light when hunting this thing even
though he knows that'll protect him and
he didn't hand this thing over to a more
professional research or an animal
control person or friggin anybody that
be more qualified he'll that jerk-off
probably deserves that lethal injection
perfect doesn't this guy just eat fit
play biology you know what fucking I
don't want know how we got those things
this guy's bizarre enough already don't
be afraid there's no reason to be afraid
a lot of people know that Howie Mandel
did the voice of gizmo but did you also
know that Frank Welker the voice of
Megatron did stripe and Mohawk white at
Michael Winslow we did the police
academy sound effects were the other
half of the gremlins funny seeing how
Bubba Smith had a cameo - how about Tony
Randall from The Odd Couple being the
voice of the sophisticated gremlin talk
a little bit about what's going on in
this
because I think there's some fascinating
ramifications here for the future a lot
of work went into making these many
distinct voices but ironically howie
mandel found his one voice for gizmo got
him not one not two but three jobs from
it hey when you got it wanted go to the
string or the sting
a lot of people wonder what the
reference is with the movie theater
showing a boy's life and watch the skies
as neither of those were actual movies
at the time well both of these names
were the working title for another
steven spielberg project he was working
on you might know it a little better as
et but don't worry just because they
didn't get the title right yet doesn't
mean they couldn't get in some early
marketing many of us known the
theatrical and DVD version of gremlins -
the movie is stopped for a moment and
taken over by our little monsters in the
projector room however for the VHS
version the gremlins take over your
television set and rather than putting
on another film reel like they did in
the original they start changing the
channels and invading other movies get
the hell off my spread as clever as this
is let's face it a bad John Wayne
impression is nothing compared to the
Hulkster telling them to get back to the
story do you think the gremsters stand
up to the hulkster you tell him Hulk
sorry folks
it won't happen again
[Music]
the movies make it clear that water
allows the mug lights to multiply and
yet they can consume tons of bottles of
beer okay and dig through the snow
without any problem is this the same
kind of reasoning that didn't fry gizmo
when he was clearly walking out during
the day who knows I'm still trying to
figure out that after midnight argument
with these guys what if one of them eats
something at 11 o'clock but didn't get
something stuck in his now he didn't eat
that after mmit billy's boss is so used
to having people do things for her that
she even has somebody take care of her
breath with mouth spray I guess that's
better than having your breath smell
like chocolate mousse pop up some porn
[Music]
how the fuck does gizmo Drive a toy car
yeah it's cute and everything but does
it have a little gas and brake pedal is
there really a forward and reverse
setting in his feet does it take gas is
it unleaded I'm sorry this really
bothers me it's just it bothers me
[Music]
vectorscope lab is also the name of the
lab from inner space another Joe Dante
film on top of that the late-night movie
that's being previewed in the film is
called optimum which was the first film
that gremlins - effects man Ray Baker
worked up yeah he's come a bit of a way
since that well I would call these some
pretty goddamn major bugs wouldn't you
[Music]
when the gremlins send the dognapper out
the window you ever noticed this picture
almost looks like he's watching her fly
out with delight I would as well to see
this bitch get her comeuppance she's so
mean and cruel she makes grown men do
this Oh
what do I love that so much Oh
[Music]
how come the cops never help Santa I
mean I know they're bad cops and all but
good God could you do a little bit of
your job now well I guess they get their
deserts when you see him crash into an
Insurance Building after cake is Billy
out of jail he tries to repay her by
stealing flowers from one of the mimes
it doesn't seem to work by the way what
are they arresting them for anyway again
that just really bothers me I think
whoever owned this film projector really
wanted Joe Dante to notice them see
[Music]
while originally the clamp TV network
was supposed to be a satire of dumb down
oversaturated media a lot of the
channels they created really do exist
now there is a Cooking Channel there is
a horror channel there's even a home and
safety channel at the time they were
mocking this idea I guess some greedy
bastards took a look at and said why not
now was that civilized no clearly not
Bob but in no sense civilized the car
outside the gas station is an AMC
Gremlin
and the number one thing you never knew
about gremlins is all the sci-fi
references being a fan of classic sci-fi
films Joe Dante put in a lot of
references to other famous monster
flicks like that's the robot from
Forbidden Planet Christopher Lee is seen
holding a pod from invasion of the Body
Snatchers and at the convention we see
HD Welles is classic design for the time
machine in the background now that's not
funny enough we see it spontaneously
vanish in the very next shot and all the
people are looking around trying to
figure out what happened to it that is
fucking hilarious
maybe he's off to tell guy piers not to
do the remake whatever reason these
little details are what makes gremlins
and gremlins two tons of fun to watch
over and over again
there anymore that you noticed are there
are little touches we're talking about
well leave them in the comments below
and keep talking about movie that's
definitely we're talking about
I'm not a Schnauzer Critic I remember it
so you don't have to
[Music]